and we all are welcome everybody welcome
back to you know well actually you don't
know so let's do it here welcome back to
your favorite podcast you know
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back once again everybody we
don't be you know we live right now so I
think I got the technical difficulties
figured out but welcome to so we can be
talking about Tiger King and I got like
a special Skype call popping all right
we did that got a new singing mic I had
to get because that was all messed up
wait let me get in here let me see what
just chad is talking about so hello chat
you guys are behind but it is what it is
and I put a Instagram thing up just
thoughts on the Tiger king it is now
Fridays 3 o'clock Pacific time and I'm
live because what else do I have to do
so I appreciate you guys in the chat you
know saying whatever you're gonna say
doing whatever you're gonna do you know
we if you saw the tiger King and that's
what I'm here to discuss today what a
weird-ass documentary but first of all
let me just say there's a help everybody
out there's be is safe I'm in California
and they just put a thing up about
everybody should wear a mask so I got
masks coming I mean I don't think
everybody has a mask and and gloves and
other things you're supposed to need but
you know just try to do your part you
know social distancing we got to keep it
going so you know we can stay alive so
we can keep it we can manage the virus
so more people can we could get back to
normal life that's what it is cuz if we
if we can manage it that we could just
we can easily get back to normal life
well not easily but we'll be able to get
back to normal life because we'll know
where it is everybody's gonna get tested
there's so many to coming out with new
tests so just be patient hang in there I
know it's hard but please hang in there
you know what I mean anyways
so damn let's get into this right let's
talk about this weird ass um documentary
that I just saw you know I mean like
Tiger king okay
actually before even going into Tiger
King III do let me go into this Skype
call first this Skype calls funny
this is mr. Jeremiah Watkins and then
we're gonna go we gonna delve into we
will delve into it but here we go
Oh walk-ins Oh is he a [ __ ] that up guys
sorry Joe exotic yeah got it
are you serious tiger King oh yeah
that's me I don't know what you're
saying that guy I'm right here in front
of you so so tell people what you've
been doing Joe exotic what have I been
doing well I just actually broke out in
prison back at Joe Ghatak studios so
this is one of my first streaming videos
I got the production team over there
it's helping me out and Eric Griffin
actually reached out to me and I said
you know what the hell I mean why not
let's start going back on the internet I
love being out here and the public side
so I hate you were you hit me up your
big play when my Netflix series Tiger
king and your people reached out to my
people which is just you hit me directly
okay so what do you think of the success
of your series mr. exotic oh I mean it's
just it's just nice to know that I have
so many fans around the world you know
what I mean it's just it's really nice
to know that people are finally digging
my country songs and and and digging my
art you know my merch sales have gone up
tremendously and I also as well as my
album sales so uh feeling pretty good
about myself so doing this quarantine
you're still thriving
well technically people think I'm in
prison right now because that's where
the documentary left itself but I
actually broke out of prison and I'm
living the King's life right now I mean
I look I have another animal right next
to me this is a giraffe that I've got
right here I'm starting to get animals
all over again and it's a good deal oh
no more animal cruelty for you though no
no no this this this giraffe is here on
his own volition mm-hmm he looks really
happy to be there yeah he's stuffed with
joy he's stuffed with joy so um is
Jeremiah well I'm just curious is he
there with you you got the good friends
right I mean he's one of the producers
over here jokes out at studios now he's
been helping me how do you want to do
you want to talk with him yeah I want to
hear more about what else does Jerome I
do for the studio I don't know what what
is him producing the show look like he's
responsible for the blinds okay wrangle
this this draft in a wild for me as well
you know Jeremiah start to go down here
yeah yeah he's a go-getter he is an
entrepreneur but I've never seen one
before yeah yeah all right well if you
around yeah I mean I know I don't get
him I mean you got to start a show right
here Dyer King Joe got it but I mean I
get that good go get that guy yeah I
mean you know we're kind of friends I
just kind of you know I called him I
didn't know that you had hijacked his
his blinds and his you know his area
yeah yeah he gave me a cell phone yeah
yeah you know what while we're waiting
for uh-oh he gave you
all right yeah yeah Eric can I ask you a
question yes go ahead
all right and when you're watching born
do you like it when the guy with the
little thing does or do you like it when
the guy big thing does I'm not actually
looking at the thing so I try not to
even notice it so I'm not I'm not like I
see it but I'm not like oh that one's
dirty that looks better you know what I
mean because then you start to think
about things like well damn and that
that's a lot how she taking that then
you stuck in a band just like you get
lost in to everything about it you know
so you admit that you get lost in the
couch I didn't know $3 bills were gay
they're queer as daylight oh my god you
know sometimes man I swear to god you uh
so-so whoo
you've had you've had boyfriend's or the
same time two men at the same time what
were they all - yeah two men at the same
time or one Eric Griffin Oh
[Laughter]
oh my god a lot of honestly a lot of
these references and stuff would help if
you would haven't seen my Netflix show
you have not seen my Netflix show right
I haven't
watch - yet I want to go over your head
a little bit and I gotta say though from
look so from the poster and looking at
you now you've lost a lot of weight you
are and it seems to evolve onto your
nose what happened prison food sometimes
is strained and sometimes ship your
metabolism like that and I got my nose
hit in a race riot in prison and it's a
little bit bigger than than usual they
allow you to have that kind of facial
here in prison oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] yet okay well thank you uh Joe
anxiety you've had the energy of getting
your taxes done this entire video
conversation so uh let me get let me go
get our see that Jeremiah carried
somewhere around there okay are you go
good okay well that was that that was
Jeremiah Jeremiah Watkins my good buddy
Jeremiah Watkins okay so I want to go in
let's talk about this [ __ ] so I saw
the series I actually watched all of it
last night I binge-watched I couldn't
help I thought I was gonna watch a
couple episodes but I watched the whole
thing so let's just go into it I'm gonna
tell you my thoughts about the frickin
Tiger King first of all but the judgment
I'm gonna make the the things I'm gonna
say about the people on the show that
the documentary our stroll are based off
the perception that the documentarian
put out so I don't know if these things
are true about these people but what the
documentary presented I have feelings
about all these people so first of all
there isn't a redeeming character in the
whole [ __ ] thing like everybody in
this everybody in this show is just a
[ __ ] monster you know what I mean
just a monster
you know and so you know and if you
don't know what the
things about at this point I don't know
what to tell you but you know it's just
about these like animal animal exotic
animal lovers these and then the seedy
business that goes with it right so
first I want to say like all the
characters it's funny how they think
that they're different but they're
pretty much all the same even Carroll
like if I wanted to start with her you
know what I mean and I even let let me
go I we can eat we can even go to the
web here to take a look at what this
looks like
you know this chick here Carol you know
like what do I have to say about Carol
you know what I mean like she thinks
that she's I found her to be just as
terrible as all the people there she
actually was the same as them like what
I find about all these the main players
right wait let me look and see like all
the main players like the main guys like
the dot guided feel had on this podcast
the ant ant ample guy Joe exotic what's
the other guy um Eric Eric no no no not
Eric oh he he he was a with that Jeff
low guy so okay so Jeff low Carol Joe
exotic and all of those guys that were
like running the zoos the animal people
they all were the same so like they all
felt like cult leaders you know what I
mean they all felt like they freakin
like they had followers you know like
they were some sort of religious feel to
it you know like the one guy the doc guy
dis muhfucka was he was no better than
like one of those like Mormon combines
that they have on he's got like five six
seven eight wives I mean the one girl
that was on there she was at you know
admitting like oh well I was young I was
impressionable and and she was saying
that she did all kinds of stuff
breast breast augmentation and all this
kind of stuff so this guy's having sex
with all these young girls he's getting
he's using the Tigers to lure him in and
he just was like this charismatic guy
and he was just like a cult leader the
dot guy doc ant pool guy so he you know
so he had that and then I realized after
you watching it and watching every
episode you go there actually
all the same like Joe had a harem of
these guys around him and that's just a
not just a gay element like forget the
fact that he made supposedly these who
guys were really straight but they
needed drugs and money but he still had
something charismatic about him that it
was okay for them to them and he still
ended up with another guy but not just
that he had like these downtrodden
people these people they needed hope so
he would go to the bus stop and like
people would be coming into town and
he'd be like are you I'm gonna give you
a place to stay and a job and a hundred
something dollars a week and you're
gonna work 48 hours a day and for me and
they started to follow him and he I mean
you watch the series and I mean you have
to like Joe exotic you how do you how do
you hate the guy you know what I mean
like you almost believed like that yes
he cared about the animals at first
right he cared about them and then it
just turned into something else because
the money in the innate he's a
narcissist you know he loved the fame he
loved the attention and I do believe he
loved the animals but he had a way that
you just you just wanted to follow him
you know and so be healed it turns out I
mean he he wasn't the best guy I mean
they didn't really tap into enough like
the drugs I wish they would have talked
more about that you just realized it
later because his like one of his
boyfriends what was the kid's name
Jonathan Finlay Finlay whatever his name
is I mean he had to crack teeth like
that [ __ ] was like I was like he's
buying them trucks and guns and all this
stuff like fix this [ __ ] teeth
like this [ __ ] was like one snaggle over
here black so I know that's like meth
teeth they call it so so you knew like
he was you know he got that's how he got
but I think that Joe himself was doing
drugs he obviously was on drugs too
you know he was not handling himself
well but it just was he just a
fascinating character you know when he
just was like a glimpse into this weird
world but all these people seem to be
cult leaders you know so the
and then the John Lowe guy that
[ __ ] is just a criminal he just
he just was like a conman criminal stole
the park from Joe but even he had a
bunch of followers he's like using these
tigers and animals he got just this one
young girl that like she's letting him
do whatever the [ __ ] he wants he's
looking for nannies he looking for hot
nannies and she's having threesomes with
him and they're in Vegas and but then
he's lying about a Ferrari lying about
his mansion you know he's just conning
people left and right I don't know why
i'ma [ __ ] oh it's not has not been
arrested I don't know why he's not in
jail okay so like all right so anyway
let's stay on Joe exotic so Joe you know
weird upbringing weird childhood the
fact that he was a gay redneck and just
all the things about him that just was
just so captivating and amazing to watch
you know just a train wreck of it and
that's why by the way that guy Rick
Kirkham
the guy that was filming the reality
show I don't that guy was a piece of
[ __ ] too in my opinion because he knew
exactly what was happening he made the
guy sign a sign something probably a
lawyer didn't look at it and so they
have like all of this you know he's got
all this footage and he's he's filming
everything Joe doesn't even have the the
sense to be like yo maybe don't film me
saying some illegal [ __ ] over here or
like I'm wonder what what footage they
really had there had to have been drug
use they had to have been all kinds of
like a nefaria [ __ ] going on that just
got Rick and then he like tried to it's
like so I'm jumping ahead in this thing
like you know when the studio got burned
down Joe first sure burn that [ __ ] now
he first sure burned it down
like based off watching the documentary
and the facts that were given in the
documentary like we don't know if all
that [ __ ] was true we don't know if what
they presented was if it was just a
narrative that the the documentarian was
trying to put forth but if it's true the
facts that he showed there of course Joe
burned the [ __ ] down you know he was
getting investigated and at that point
we didn't know we didn't know watching
the documentary that he you know was
involved with having the other woman
killed her and uh
you know but we don't know you know if
that was even true he's saying it wasn't
true but it's hard to it's hard to know
what's true or not true based off these
facts
so he burned that place down because you
know that the feds were asking him the
cops were asking him questions the
people are suing him so he was like all
this information he probably has
something on that tape that was like
damning and they were gonna confiscate
the whole [ __ ] and watch it and see all
kinds of [ __ ] that he didn't want them
to see so he was like [ __ ] this burn
that [ __ ] down burn all the hard drives
so jail was just a weird character and
like I say I feel like all of those
people had the same kind of thing even
Carroll like let's talk about Carroll
like do I think she killed her husband
based off the facts that they showed
yeah I think she killed her husband I
think she was she I think she's a
cold-blooded did get what she wants type
of lady like dolls ex-wives and the
daughter or if they were all ex-wives
those women [ __ ] hate her like they
were like she did it like like that one
to older the older wife man huh she was
so bitter but I get it you know she's
not acting young she thought she was the
young pretty thing you know he was gonna
love you forever
so anyways and then like okay so I know
I'm scatterbrained right now cuz I'm
doing this live but look here's what I
think about Carol I think Carol if Joe
wasn't gay she would have been attracted
to Joe exotic I think she because he's
just like the husband he's just like the
husband is she that allegedly got rid of
cuz she was did she hear her story she's
19 he drives by her to three times and
then it's like getting a car and talked
to me you know and uh you could hold
this gun on me like [ __ ] you don't get
it to a [ __ ] car he's a hold
this gun on me like what like that says
something about her whole psyche and I'm
I know she had a horrible experience
when she was 14 she said she she
allegedly says that she was raped by
three men that by knifepoint so you know
how that's affected her for the rest of
her life and to the point where now
she's getting into a strange man's car
that has it gives her a gun and then of
course she goes with him she that was
all sexy to her
you know she goes with him and there it
is you know what I mean so it's like
damn it was that she was bizarre so then
she gets with this guy he's got all this
money and then he's cheating on her
obviously cuz he was with because they
were together for years before he left
his wife
so like listen if you get with some if
you a side chick okay if you a side
chick and then you become the main chick
[ __ ] don't think that you don't be the
main chick forever you're not gonna you
don't got you don't got that thing
that's gonna make this guy go oh this is
the one you know I've been cheating and
screwing around
for a long time but now no you ain't
special you know so he was gonna be in
Costa Rica with another girlfriend so
she what I'm saying is that guy was
charismatic that guy had a bunch of
girlfriends and a bunch of money and she
was enamored by that I mean but she
herself three four husbands and you know
she was just like Joe she she she she
had this engaging personality so she's
online you know what I didn't appreciate
about her the hypocrisy like how they
laid the the document the duck the the
what do you call it whatever the dock
docu-series out how they laid it out you
didn't know about her past
so they telling her is this like great
animal rights activist and she's like
trying to shut these things down
turns out this [ __ ] was doing
that that's how she made her money and
then they show her current park I don't
see the difference from a distance from
a helicopter view if I'm in a helicopter
and I'm flying over Joe exotics Park I'm
flying over doc antle's Park I'm flying
over that other Tim guy's Park whoever
owns these parks if I'm flying over them
and I fly over Carol's place how the
[ __ ] would you know the difference all I
see is big-ass cats and animals in cages
and people in line to look at them like
I don't know how she's able to take the
high road take this high road with that
being the case it just seemed weird to
me you know um I'm look I'm trying to
look at the chat too at the same time
guys I'm sorry there's so much going on
in the chat that I my mom
Raina's going haywire you know so that's
the thing I didn't appreciate about her
and then then so maybe she she changed
her tune maybe you know after maybe you
know I think that she was mad at her
ex-husband okay so you know she's a
vindictive like go get her she's gonna
get what she wants that's how she's
portrayed that's how those other women
felt about her so if you believe that to
be true I think it was all vengeance it
was like all right I'm gonna have this
part and anybody that has a part that's
like my ex-husband they going down not
just for the animals like the one chick
who got her arm cut off that's how much
Joe gets in people's head that's how
much people were loyal to him this
[ __ ] got her arm bitten off and
seven days later she back at work you
know I was like what so and she said it
best at the end of the documentary like
no animals were looked after in this
everybody was looking out for themselves
and their own self-interest like what is
her what is her take in his house and
his mattress and his trucks and his and
his trailer and all the [ __ ] all the
money how the [ __ ] was that helping all
those animals in Joe's Park like you
know that's what I thought she was
trying to do so I don't know I think
that Joe Joe and all those guys that
she's going after are just like the
husband that she got rid of allegedly
you know what I mean allegedly she
killed to kill her husband but you know
the way she is
how send in 7,000 emails and and like
mushy doesn't stop and she had a weird
demeanor like every time she would just
laugh you'd like like why would I kill
my husband oh you know I was like oh she
she came across to me it's creepy but
she's already come out and said that
that she was portrayed come not in a
good light and I could see that I could
see how when you make a documentary you
have your own narrative and this is the
narrative of that so I just say again I
think they're all cult leaders including
her on her third or fourth husband with
her with her ex-husband's millions in
the bank you know she
I believe those ex ex wives who were
like she
told me if we say anything that she's
gonna make sure we have nothing I mean
she just seems like a vengeful
vindictive woman who's like you know who
is disguising that with like oh I care
about animals because I didn't get the
impression that she cared about animals
I just got the impression that she liked
wearing cat [ __ ] and hated these guys
you know and they hated her in return
like let's go back to Joe just for a
second just [ __ ] insane hey he
was like shootin a doll on the internet
talking about it was her so like even if
something even if I say he would hire
somebody to kill her
he still would have been the suspect
there's enough circumstantial evidence
probably to have a case against him
maybe he doesn't get convicted but it's
like dude he don't know how to shut his
mouth alright so there's that guy and
Carol I just think tit and then she had
her husband like I don't know who that
Howard guy I don't get his fascination
with he took on the cause to like they
just both seemed like angry like we're
gonna get you type people they didn't
care how much money they were gonna
spend they would they would have spent
millions to make sure these people went
down and they succeeded I think you know
I don't know so then going back to the
dock anthro guy who like he just was on
Theo's podcast I haven't watched it I
wanted to watch it before I did this but
I just been busy today but like Theo
like you know he had him on in it but
I'm saying that guy that guy is he he's
like Jim Jones or you know I mean he's
like one of these like charismatic like
cult leaders he just happens to have
animals you know what I mean so like but
I don't know if he's I think they all
did a legal [ __ ] like that the saddest
part about it is they all did the same
thing the the puppy the the the Cubs you
know people come to pet to Cubs and then
when they're not manageable and you have
to spend ten thousand dollars a day to
feed them or ten thousand dollars a
month or whatever that price was they
said where they had to feed these
animals they were like [ __ ] that just
kill him make some new ones I mean it
was sad and it was also sad to see that
number that it was something like
six to ten thousand there's six to ten
thousand Tigers in the United States and
only four thousand in in the wild I mean
that's crazy man
so that guy was a cult leader you know
and then that's going to this Jeff Lowe
guy so this guy he he scammed Joe I mean
Joe was obviously on drugs not in his
right mind he was paranoid
he was already scheming I think that
they both schemed to kill this lady I
think they but because Carol was trying
to get all of them
whoever has animals she was like you're
on my radar and I'm coming for your ass
so they all hit him even like one
reasonable guy the manager of the let me
see if I can find his [ __ ] name what
is his name um John rinky like he seemed
to be the most reasonable guy but even
he was like at the end he was like man
[ __ ] artists he left his wife he was
living in a trailer like I'm done I'm
done with the world I've suffered enough
I lost my lion so here I am so that guy
was crazy you know he he even though he
seemed to be like the nicest of all
these weird people even he ended up
making some bad decisions he knew what
was going on I could tell he has some
guilt you know what I mean I could tell
he has some guilt all right let's go to
the chat see what people are saying well
the number somebody said the number is
fake about the Tigers well you know I
don't know you stink you okay somebody
says the government sent Jeff flow to
stop Joe no okay you know two people
that I thought were like real pieces of
[ __ ] in this and that's one is Jeff flow
and the other one is this guy James
let's get him on the screen this dude
right here this dude right here that
dude right there
he was a he he was a [ __ ] too
dizzy they all they all had their
self-interest
it was also fit dressed so you have that
guy you know and then you had the Jeff -
Jeff flow guy where's Jeff flow let's
get him on a screen - so you had James
you had James and you had Jeff flow
right these two [ __ ] you know
what I mean so all right so Jeff flow
comes into the picture I still don't
understand his story you know I think
that I just think that he's a
an artist I think that he's really good
at that I mean you know he Joe was in a
bind like Carol was beating his ass down
he had he lost all of his like
possessions like the expensive
possessions and she was coming for the
park she was gonna get that park at it
was gonna be him or nothing so this guy
preyed on him you know what I mean I
think he preyed on him he got away he
got to park
he got these animals he got Joe and then
I think too he I think he himself wanted
Carol gone too the way he was talking
you know he just was like he just
sounded like a mafioso guy you know like
the one mafia guy in the show - what was
that guy's name the dude that was like
like Scarface a lot for my little friend
oh man what was that dude's name um you
guys know who I'm talking about though
if you watch the show I mean there's so
many people oh no it wasn't him wasn't
John um what the [ __ ] was that guy's
name anyways you know the other mobster
guy that like you know he had cats
he had the tigers and lions and [ __ ] and
then he while he was a and he was
selling drugs to like for his like
exotic animal habit you know he was
talking about like you know he did the
things that these people like it freely
admitted was like bizarre to be like
this guy was basically saying that he
was a part of chopping somebody's head
off with a chainsaw or son [ __ ] I don't
know it just was like so that guy was
weird so that guy I believe that guy
more than anybody else of him just being
like oh yeah he's guilty that guy's
guilty so that guy was weird um but this
guy's so Jeff flow he comes in he makes
Joe Joe think he's gonna help him he
does help him he helps him in a way that
he's like he he fronts some money I bet
you it wasn't even really his money's
probably somebody else's money and he
basically took the park over and then
Joe didn't he don't trust anybody he's
not a reputable dude you know he's not
an honorable guy Joe Joe he [ __ ] you
know was doing all this shady [ __ ] on
the side you know I I think they all
were
involved we're talking about could look
they got Joe on tape making the plans to
kill Carol they got him on tape so he's
no matter what he says they got his ass
on tape all right but he's having a
conversation with the other guy like I
think they're just Jeff Lowe guy he got
immunity I don't know why the government
hated Joe exotic more than they hated
all these [ __ ] nefarious characters
you know what I mean it don't make any
sense to me okay let me look in here and
see Jeff got caught yeah so like yes
this guy Jeff Lowe he's in Vegas doing
crimes he's all over the country doing
crimes got a fake Ferrari a fake house
it's not his so like so I think that he
I don't think the government would the
government wasn't using him I think he
was using the government I think that he
was like look I got this guy I could get
this is like a serious crime he wants to
kill this woman I'll get him for you and
you give me immunity on that and some
other things and they probably said okay
well the lesser of two evils they're
both terrible I think the animal people
were the ones that made the deal like
okay cool because Joe had more animals
you know Joe had access to more animals
this big zoo that was like 70 animals
there so he's like you know but I think
that guy's going down I do think he's
going down okay so anyways so he brings
on they all had criminals around them
what's the one guy's name what's that
one guy's name oh it Sam right they had
the they had the Sam guy that
[ __ ] why is he not in jail he
was straight up like I cut the bitch's
head off like he's trying to say that he
took Joe's money just to [ __ ] with him
and like just played along but part of
me there is part of me that thinks that
Geoff set this whole [ __ ] up they Jeff
initiated we there's probably phone
calls with Joe that we never heard or
there's interaction like that's what did
phat death that's what phat Chucky was
saying James that guy was saying that he
knows that Geoff is a part of it that
there were other he was
there when they discussed it and I think
the Jeff pushed Joe along Joe's easily
manipulated he pushed and pushed and
pushed him and then Joe and then at the
point where Joe let's say the
conversation they had before that is Joe
going like okay yeah yeah we should kill
her you right okay so how do we do it
and then the [ __ ] starts
recording you know what I mean so we
don't know I think it's entrapment you
know I think yeah anyways I don't know
you guys get what I'm saying and just I
don't think that I don't think that Jeff
flow should be scot-free I think that he
has more involvement in that whole plot
because he even his saying remember the
parties that the tree is all like yeah
I'm not gonna lie I wanted her dead -
she did the world will be better off if
she was dead even the nice dude I was
talking about even the manager the nice
guy he was saying like look I've even
said it she should die that's how
vicious that's how that's how she was on
top of all those guys where they hated
her so much they wanted her dead
who you know what I mean
so I'm going back to chat see what you
guys are saying it's on tape Jeff
telling the guy he needed to tell the
feds this and that I know honey dude I
totally agree like they they got they
didn't show everything there's more to
this there's more to it you know and I
wouldn't be surprised if the TV producer
guy who got all his stuff burned up if
some place on those tapes
there was the conversations about
something like that you never know you
know but this guy Sam I don't get how
he's not in jail like he accepted the
money he he can't come later and be like
I was just kidding or I was trying to
mess with him I don't get why that guy
is dad that's just freaky dad desk
that's some freaky [ __ ] you know what I
mean oh god I don't know guys
I see somebody's put bringing up a point
shouldn't a filmmaker be in trouble for
not stopping it I mean at what point you
know I know in Florida I think in
Florida there's a law that if you
witness a crime and you don't do
anything you can get arrested I'm not
sure if that's how the law is what do
you call it I'm not sorry that's how you
say it or that's that's how it's written
but it's something like that like
because remember there was like there
was just like college beach party or
something like that going on and a girl
is being raped and some people filmed it
you know and you know it's like what
what are you doing like filming it like
what if you're somebody that's like okay
I'll film it okay so we get to evidence
but you seven eight nine twenty people
standing around why don't you guys stop
it like let's work together so I don't
know I don't know how culpable the the
filmmaker actually is because again
you know it's a narrative he's so he's
taking pieces of the story and putting
it together and we're we were presented
the story in a way that were like it
looks like really bad for all of them
they all look really bad I don't know if
Jeff flow was really this horrible
person but he's presented that way I
don't know in like this is the weasel
guy like that guy James fat Chucky he
freaking looked he came across terrible
in my opinion like he just was a slimy
trying to get out of it kind of guy I
mean they had like I didn't know that
the Gaming Commission not the Gaming
Commission but the fish animal and fish
people they had the same jurisdiction
like the FBI so they had him on like
having that little ferret thing so they
had him on so you know they were gonna
turn his ass so he's like coming in
trying to like hey I got these I think I
can get these people saying some really
bad stuff so I can so I can get off I
mean they all were terrible you know
they're all terrible and I gotta give it
to Joe like he I felt for the dude man I
don't think should he be in jail I don't
know what do you guys think should he be
in jail you know should he be it like
was he terrible to the animals you
I think he he was terrible he should do
some time for just the cruelty to
animals I think he even felt it when he
was I was touched when he was talking
about the chimpanzees how he said like
for 10 years he kept him in those cages
and you know he needed when he let when
he finally gave him up to that whatever
sanctuary it was and they had they were
outside and they were hugging each other
when they first got out to cages and I
was just like damn dude you know and you
heard it in that clip and then you heard
him on the phone from jail where he was
like oh man like you could tell he was I
[ __ ] I'm being treated like I treated
the animals you know inside him Joe
sorry bro but you know you you you you
were out of control he was out of
control man the guy was he was just out
of control
Simone [ __ ] ran for governor ran for
president and then that how about that
one libertarian guy what the [ __ ] was
his name this guy wasn't to me he was a
piece of [ __ ] too
like how you gonna have how you gonna
have this it Joshua Joshua I didn't like
Joshua you know I think that he he was
taking advantage of the situation - how
you like back this guy if you I guess
that's because he was so anti-government
he was like you know the you know the
best way to be anti-government is to
have an idiot run for office cuz you
never know
sometimes I might win you know so I just
didn't I didn't believe him I didn't
trust him you know and it just got dark
you know what I mean the the the whole
the whole thing was dark you know like
when the poor drugged up kid killed
himself you know I was like damn debt
that was the moment that it all became
real I don't know about you guys but I'm
watching the documentary and I'm just
fascinated by all these terrible
characters all these terrible people all
this like that people like I'll even
like - dude whoa oh man you know the one
guy long-haired he was the manager of
the the zoo or he was at Eric the Eric
guy Eric Cowie I think that was his name
let me see if this is the guy yeah he
was the head keeper of the zoo
man when they let me show him for you
guys this guy right here oh man you know
like when they showed him remember when
they showed him he was in this like room
or something and it's just like it's
just like alcohol bottles everywhere and
I didn't like I was like come on
document document document Aryan guy a
filmmaker
they just made that guy let's say he was
[ __ ] drunk and you just go look how
all of this has affected all these
peoples like none of these people are
emotionally equipped to deal with the
things that they're dealing with like I
actually don't know how does
[ __ ] ran a zoo for 20 years him
Joe all these people like how I mean
that's why did they were killing the
cats and burying him in the [ __ ] you
know he couldn't afford it in their
Walmart meat oh that's another thing too
did you guys know that did you know that
if you that is that even true and
anybody know if that's true that let's
say you go grab some meat and then you
go up to the front and you don't want it
you can't pay for it they can't put it
back I didn't know that I mean that was
so much wasted meat did you see that so
it was like I'm glad that that kind of
stuff's going someplace if you have all
these cats but that [ __ ] was crazy you
know that [ __ ] was crazy but everybody
just seemed terrible so anyways let me
get back to what I was saying so the kid
Tim what was his name what's his name
Tim wait let me see if I could get his
name did you know when he was just 9
yeah he came on 19 yet no it wasn't Tim
what was the get what was the boys named
it that killed himself oh man I wish I
wish I was more prepared I had this
thing open I thought this was gonna be
everybody's names but it wasn't I don't
know but that poor kid you know you saw
that first video of him he was just
fresh and young skater kid all pretty in
the face you know I mean just his little
stash and he was all like it's like then
he just like turned into like a [ __ ]
meth head crack [ __ ] you know shooting
pointing guns at people and it's just
you know that was the moment those like
I was
like that's that was very sobering
watching the documentary because at that
point like I said you're having fun
laughing at how crazy these people are I
mean Joe and his music - man that [ __ ]
was just hilarious like all his music
videos and his web show how weird it got
and even Carol and her [ __ ] weirdo
ass like Otto's cat stuff and just her
demeanor everybody was weird but when
that kid killed himself you know it
became real because I mean in your
getting a story you see his poor mom you
could tell that she felt like a failure
she felt like oh man she's like I failed
my kid I don't know what is he I don't
know what he was doing with this guy and
then Joe was [ __ ] up like inviting her
to his wedding to this new crazy kid you
know who like by the way from the looks
on his face and how he was talking it
looks like he legitimately loves Joe so
that's from weird [ __ ] - that's how
charismatic that [ __ ] is Joe so
it just that was sobering - when that
guy died and that's like the downfall of
it that's when like I think as a
storyteller the docket that the
filmmaker made it like okay now I'm
gonna reveal all the underbelly all the
evil that's really going on so that
really may like I went from laughing at
the documentary documentary to really
just kind of being like damn this is
this is some this is some sobering
fucked-up [ __ ] you know what I mean all
right let me go to Instagram right now
so I'm sure I have some Instagram
questions
wait how do I how do I go to the
Instagram oh here we go here we go here
we go here we go here it is alright
so wildest thing I've ever seen can't
believe this is the same world we live
in I mean I totally agree that's another
thing too is like you watch that
documentary you go is this real like
this one I'm saying I think that the
filmmaker took liberties somebody said
[ __ ] great I was rooting for Joe the
whole time you know I found myself
rooting for him too and even hearing his
phone calls from jail I kind of was like
I hope this guy gets out but then at the
same time just like damn he he is
responsible he is partly responsible for
the death of that dude he is responsible
for the mistreatment of all the animals
you know he's done some wrong she'd be
in jail for 20 years I don't know I'm
not that I'm not a judge I don't know
what's fair in terms of that but he does
should do some time first time I Carroll
did it I mean if I'm being honest with
you just just hearing everybody and just
feeling her strangeness and her
willingness to like not stop not let up
at all
I'm not does she seem like somebody to
could kill a [ __ ] yeah if I'm
being winner from being 100 okay let me
see lots of drug-induced homosexuality
oh not to mention [ __ ] Carol Baskins
well that's how people feeling you know
drug-induced homosexuality is that a
thing well I guess if you're so
desperate for like the kid was a
prisoner there say he according to the
libertarian guy the do couldn't leave
the compound
he couldn't have friends he couldn't
have his own money he had to like so he
just got drugs and we didn't you know
from from Joe oh man dude the hype is
worn off don't talk about it well too
late brother Joe is addict as a hard
worker yeah you know you gotta admire
you know what though all these kind of
guys okay think of all the like serial
killers and all the like cult leaders
organized and how hard-working and like
they are but they do it for you know
like like Obama or somebody like that
could have easily gone down the wrong
path
you know thankfully someone like Obama
went on the good path but he easily
could have been like a cult leader or
something like those type of people
could use their powers for something
other than what they end up doing it for
sex money and drugs you know what I mean
um yes a lot of people say they rootin
for him the walking Chuckie GOG I said
he's in trouble for owning a loom our
that's definitely not it
ah yeah I totally agree I think there's
more going on with that guy - yeah Fat
Chucky has more going on in his life to
put that's still a big beat we see the
some say we don't know all these guys
another thing too is they love being in
front of the camera all of them and they
didn't know how to shut their mouth it's
like the the the FBI should just look at
this documentary or just look at all the
footage and just be like this muhfucka
admitted that he did this this guy
insinuated that he did this just like
they have to me they have enough
circumstantial evidence just of what
they showed us to be like I think we
need to reinvestigate Jeff Lowen and and
and Chucky and and Sam who was a
criminal muhfucka had he was acrimony
got out of jail he was you you felt I
felt like if if Jo or whatever the
circumstances even though I think it was
a setup
part of me does feel like Jeff set him
up you know I mean like goaded him into
it you know what I mean
you know it's like if you you know it's
like if you you know you whisper in
somebody's ear your mama your mama's a
[ __ ] and then you that guy punches you
in the face and all of a sudden you're
like this oh my god dude so violent look
what this guy did I think it was a setup
like in the firm
remember the firm with Tom Cruise he
still did wrong he shouldn't have slept
with that chick on the beach but it was
a setup you know nothing like Joe
shouldn't have got money together to
kill Carol you know he should have done
that but it was a setup you know and I
think that Sam was a part of it so like
I don't know I
think Sam would kill someone but I don't
think that he was gonna kill Carol I
think that the whole point of it was
take this [ __ ] money and get
him thrown in jail right that's what I
think of that uh uh kind of fizzles out
somebody thinks it fizzles out I thought
it was hilarious didn't you I thought it
was fun like I said I thought it was so
fun like not just funny to like
jaw-dropping like everything that Joe
did you would go what or even lo or any
of these people you hit the things that
coming out of their mouth and you go
you're doing what and then then you hear
at Joe music you hear some of his music
he just started laughing so I stopped
laughing at it the moment the guy killed
himself that was when I was done that
meatlovers pizza was a [ __ ]
wasn't it he made with the Walmart me
Joe was a businessman he was like I'm
not [ __ ] around y'all I'm you gonna
get just Walmart meat so I said I think
Carol's husband keeps his socks on while
having sex with her yeah so he could get
his shoes and run out of there before
that [ __ ] kills him um anyways so
that's from Instagram that was the the
Instagram crowd appreciate you guys and
I appreciate all you guys watching live
at home you know what I mean you know we
got a solid looks like we almost got a
solid hour in I think the times off cuz
my thing says it's been streaming for 54
minute let me go to the stream and see
what's going on where we at where we get
oh yeah 50 months so we still got time
we got I wanted to do an hour take some
questions so you know anything else
somebody said 5,000 is a ridiculously
low for a hit man you know what's funny
that that's what the doc guy said to I
think he said the same thing I think he
was some like $100,000 job but you know
but to me that's very I don't know how
much a hit man cost I hope I never know
how much a hit man cost but if you so
sure about how much a hit man cost what
kind of world are you living in like who
are you to know that kind of information
greetings from Germany hello Germany how
you guys doing
um Tiger king is lame uh you know I
think it's kind of lame ish I'm not you
know what let's talk about my mustache
you know Lucy should I get a Joey
exactly
guys I don't know if I'm a girl to
mustache back but I do like having some
some fuzz you know what I mean I don't
know if I want to be clean again like
that like I when I first did it but I
kind of like my face I'm kind of getting
used to it and then when I look at
pictures of myself with the mustache I'm
kind of like who the [ __ ] is that you
know what I mean so it's uh I'm not sure
my mom is okay my mom's here in
California with my stepfather they're
there you know at her place and they're
they're doing okay it's just hot you
know it's just hard right now to like
keep them you know stay inside you know
people don't really I don't think it's
touched every you know it's affected us
just coronavirus has affected us but it
hasn't touched us it hasn't touched all
of us yet you know grow a full beard I
was thinking about it but then it just
it's too Scratchy and I don't like it
stop dude I I had my I washed my hands
you know I'm gonna wash my face and
hands right after this podcast y'all all
right you know I'm trying to do the
podcast with Steve I'm trying to you
know but you know Steve's in his own
world man he's doing his podcast and
he's like you know hunkered in he's you
know so I don't know we'll see after all
this clears up we'll see what happens I
didn't realize my upper lip was so small
you think you like this [ __ ] is like I
need some Connie some injections in my
lip I I first did it I was like where
the [ __ ] is my top lip it's like this
was made for a mustache it's crazy I
know see it's like I'm getting mixed
reviews like people say so how about in
the chat let me know like just put keep
it just put keep no once we say yes or
no so yes no wait what was she
I'm confusing myself just say mustache
or no mustache and I'm busy playing what
do you call it a war zone I'm still
playing call of duty I'm still trying to
get a black ops win so if you go if you
want ever want to watch me game go to
era
Gaming Eric Griffin gaming on YouTube
that's my other channel Eric Griffin
gaming so make sure you check that out
my thanks to Jeremiah Watkins who like I
hadn't watched the documentary yet when
he came on to do that and I didn't even
know he was gonna do that it was just he
just surprised me with that because
that's what he does he's so committed to
his characters so that's why the
interview seemed weird cuz I didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was talking but um so
he was saying no stache goatee keep it
sandy I like the sand eNOS - keep the
fuzz no stache nose - nose - nose - nose
- it's all nose test
okay well must add there's one moustache
vote another moustache vote another
moustache vote handlebar moustache go
[ __ ] yourself I know we're trying to get
the podcast going 20/20 nose - I don't
know I know I look like a like a skinny
red man I do like on my face a little
bit more as slender I've been keeping
[ __ ] uh I mean I'm I'm not eating a lot
you know I mean I'm eating healthy
trying to lose this weight y'all so when
we come out of this [ __ ] I'm gonna be a
whole new man ready for ready for
sitcoms and [ __ ] cop shows and [ __ ]
you know want to see me on a cop show
doo doo doo doo
you know I want to be on like I don't
know my dream job is to be like the lab
tech on CSI one of those type shows I
want to be like that you know so like
the main guys they come in to go you
know Roscoe their name will be Roscoe
now I got music blasting the [ __ ] I'm
looking at the tech and I'm like oh my
bad sir boom um according to the red
blood cells boo boo I do like you know I
got like two good scenes in every
episode and I'm just on a road doing
stand-up you know what I mean that would
be the best and then second the show
goes like 15 years those people make so
much money I love your vibes - you want
my stash or clean well my girl she's
like she don't like the mustache she
just like I'm gonna talk I think Bobby I
just talked to Bobby today so I'm
probably gonna have Bobby on so we'll
see y'all have I don't get a lot of
people I got my buddy Brett Ernst he's
gonna come on I got an edge with Santino
I talked to him
even though that episode is still a
little the wall is wonky with the sound
and all that but I'm about to time about
to record myself talking about that when
I get off with you guys and yeah that's
um that's pretty much that's pretty much
that
Oh check you on twitch chat I know I
would love to be in a buddy cop movie
with Bobby Lee you know what I mean but
it's like it was it looks to rush hour
II but it's not you know but that would
be the joke like we should do like a
spoof of rush hour that's the whole
point of it like we're garbage men and
we find like some evidence and a we find
out like a bag of money that we realize
it's not ours it belongs to the mob and
some [ __ ] and we have to like you know I
mean look look I just wrote the movie
right there
you guys know where that goes okay
there's a hole Mike says I need a
mustache
alright I'm not getting a mullet exactly
know what I did actually decide to shave
the mustache myself guys I did cuz I was
like I'm bored I'm gonna be in the house
and who cares I'm not you know the who
long home I get girls back fast as [ __ ]
you'd be surprised
I also wanted to see actually how gray I
was actually and I have a weird black
streak like my hair growth is still
black in a weird area like I have like
like it would be like it would be like
here and it would come like this and
everything around it would be gray it's
really weird-looking so I don't know I
might grow to beer just to see what that
looks like
I always stream war zone if you go to
Eric Griffin gaming Eric Griffin gaming
on YouTube that's my other channel where
I gain so you know guys check that out
you know what I mean
but anyways I really appreciate you guys
watching I really paid you know like I
said I love that you guys are watching
I'm gonna do a live one every Friday
doing quarantine I'm trying to put out
as much content as I can because I'm
still trying to be creative and I'm
still trying to stay connected all the
people that send me messages and say
like yo man I really love your podcast
you're helping me through these times I
really appreciate those messages because
you're helping me too when you send me
that message and I know I'm reaching
people and that's what it's all about so
even when you get off this podcast right
now share it for me share it like it
subscribe send it out to people man you
that's how you help me out and watch the
ads that's if you really want to help me
out I'm trying to do my part do your
part
just you know play my podcast in the
background just open up a web browser
and just go to my riffing with Griffin
playlists you know in my on my page and
just let it play with the hats it's
going cuz that'll help me out maybe you
don't have to do that I'm just I'm being
I'm being half playful you know what I
mean but I appreciate all you guys you
know what I mean
and as you know once again is your
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]